[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle icare et
aujourd'hui je vous racontais une
discussion que j'ai eue avec mes cousins
qui a 8 ans donc c'était le réveillon du
nouvel an toute la famille était à table
voyez une soirée festive et on était
divisée en deux tables les adultes et
les enfants est dans le camp des enfants
et donc on parlait du film le roi lion
qu'on avait vu l'après midi et tout à
coup mon cousin
je vous ai dit la 8 ans et me demande
pourquoi est-ce qu'à la télévision les
animaux il parle comme nous et puis dans
la vraie vie parle pas et donc moi je
regardais déjà ma grand mère qui est en
train d'apporter le gâteau un gâteau au
chocolat
du coup je pensais pas à ça et je lui
réponds bêtement écoute c'est comme ça
dans la vraie vie
nous on parle les humains et les animaux
et parle pas voilà mais il est pas
rester comme ça il me dit mais à la fin
on est tous des animaux non pourquoi est
ce qu'on ne parle pas tous et il va même
jusqu au point de me supplier de lui
répondre avec son petit visage d'enfant
il ne s'en envoyer comme ça on est donc
je me dis comment lui dire non du coup
je lui dis après le dessert on va dans
ma chambre et je t'explique un peu si tu
veux et ce fait on peut situer donc
mange le délicieux gâteau au chocolat et
et puis on va dans ma chambre je
l'emmène voilà je reprends mon cours de
biologie et lui donne la réponse
scientifique à ces questions je lui dis
que les humains tout comme tout comme
les autres animaux on ancêtre commun qui
est la bactérie est donc cette date ces
bactéries
elle est apparue il ya 3,6 milliards
d'années et que à partir de celle-ci on
a donc des nouvelles espèces sont
apparus et donc ont évolué au fil du
temps pour retrouver les diverses
espèces actuelles qui qu'on a maintenant
et donc aujourd'hui maintenant nous les
homo sapiens sommes les élus
certains disent c'est à dire qu'on est
l'espèce qui s'est le plus développé
donc c'est à dire que c'est l'espèce qui
dominent le monde actuel et pour
répondre à sa question de l'usi on est
les seuls à avoir pu développer un
langage articulé et élaboré notamment
grâce à notre cerveau et à notre larynx
et pas trop rester enfant il n'était pas
trop convaincu qu'avec ma réponse
scientifique et donc il me pose plus de
questions il me dit ok on s'est parlé
mais est-ce qu'on est si différent que
les autres animaux de la planète à la
fin comme si on est tous des animaux
presse que c'est nous qui domine on est
jeudi
est-ce que je continue à y répondre
enfin c'est quand même la soirée du
nouvel an j'ai envie de revenir genre
elle est un peu j'en peux plus quoi mais
bon je me dis on va quand même le
continue à lui répondre parce qu'après
j'ai envie qu'ils disent que je sens qu
ayant préféré un message c'est en secret
donc je dis écoute comme c'est dit avant
on a des caractères tease des
caractéristiques beaucoup plus développé
que les autres animaux par exemple on
est bipèdes
c'est à dire qu'on peut marcher à deux
pieds et on a aussi un cerveau très
développé et là ils s'étonnent et me dit
mais en quoi est ce que cela est un si
grand avantage dans saab aussi des bleus
enfin un cerveau s'y développer il a
vraiment j'avais l'exemple parfait
il lui dit qu'à l'école j'avais dû faire
une enquête
en posant la question qu'est ce qui nous
rend humain aux gens et donc je montre
et quelques je lui dis que quelques
réponses sont similaires mais il ya une
chose que toutes ces réponses en commun
la réflexion en effet avant de me
répondre de me répondre à la question de
l' enquête
les gens du donc penser réfléchir à ce
qu'ils allaient me répondre et donc
cette réflexion et le fait de pouvoir
parler communiquer comme j'ai dit avant
nous rend nous est prêt aux humains et
nous a permis d'accumuler des
informations sur plusieurs générations
et donc cette transmission d'idées est à
la base du monde actuel et donc c'est
pour ça que nous dominons est pas et pas
ce n'est pas les animaux mais j'avais
quand même envie lui et enfin déjà que
je parlais j'avais envie de lui rajouter
quelques exemples je lui dis par exemple
on est la seule
on est les seuls à avoir conscience que
l'on va mourir et là il est encore
étonné pour la deuxième fois il me dit
mais regardant le roi lion comme moussa
faye mort son fils il est triste
moi je répond immédiatement oui certains
animaux réagissent quand l'un des leurs
est mort mais ils ne sont pas conscients
que eux-mêmes ils aillent mourir
lm10 mais ok mais ça change quoi qu'on
sache qu'on allait mourir va non
seulement non seulement ça nous ça nous
met une limite à notre vie on est
conscient qu'on a une limite mais ça
nous incite à tirer le meilleur parti de
la vie qu'on a à nous rendre utiles
c'est dire que sans la connaissance de
la mort la naissance de la civilisation
aurait peut-être jamais eu lieu
mais c'est vrai que le fait qu'on sache
qu'on va mourir
ça peut être aussi un peu mal parce que
ça peut mener à le fait qu'on veuille
profiter au maximum de nos temps limité
ça peut mener à comps une exploitation
excessive de nos ressources naturelles
celle-ci s'épuisent pour les prochains
pour les prochaines générations qui est
plus par exemple légèrement de votre
entreprise
les big boss logiquement leur goal
c'est quoi ils veulent leur but c'est
quoi ces deux va en tirer le maximum de
profit donc ils vont adopter et votez
pour les options rentable pas les
options durera pas les trucs vont donc
ne tiennent pas en considération les
effets que ça ça pourrait avoir au long
terme pour les pour les prêts en fin
pour le long terme de la planète pour le
bien de la planète et donc voila quand
aux animaux eux comme j'ai dit ils sont
inconscients de la mort ils n'ont donc
pas ce type de considération et donc eux
ne détruisent pas leur environnement
alors que nous y tient si tu veux du dit
tiens si tu veux je peux te montrer tels
que ces machins internet ça c'est les
dégâts les dégâts de l'homme par rapport
à son environnement totalement détruit
on peut le voir avec la pollution du
plastique et la déforestation
alors que les animaux ne sont pas
conscients de la main donc eux ils sont
totalement organisée enfin ils ont rien
on voit avec un barrage de castors et la
ruche d'abeilles enfin ils ne détruisent
pas à leur mouvement
donc c'est vrai que sur le coup on a
vraiment apprendre des animaux à
on doit penser au long terme pas qu'à
notre temps de vie limitée donc je finis
mon explication
moi j'étais à se faire de moi et lui il
est aussi assez faire de moi et même il
était aussi faire qui m'a un peu résumé
ce que j'ai dit il me dit ok on est en
fait nous les humains on est assez
différent que les autres espèces
mais pour le meilleur tout comme pour le
pire on vient de le voir même si au
début on vient tous d'un même truc d'un
petit truc comme j'ai dit une petite
bactérie
et donc voilà et qu'on était prêts de
revenir à table avec la famille
j'étais content il me dit ah attends
attends j'ai trouvé la solution pourquoi
est ce qu'on ne remplacerait pas tous
les hommes de la planète par des robots
eux ils sont ils savent parler eux sont
intelligents ils savent tout faire et on
devrait même les configurer à la
perfection pour qu'il n'ait pas
conscience de la mort et donc ils ne
détruisent pas leur environnement donc
moi immédiatement je dis tu as raison
nous enfin les robots ils ont été créées
par les humains potiche à la parfaite
représentation de l'homme pour qu'ils
puissent nous remplacer pour tout faire
pour qu'il puisse le remplacer par tous
en plus s'il est par chance les robots
se casse
on peut les remplacer alors que nous les
humains une fois qu'on est mort voilà et
mais il avait du coup ils étaient
contents il me dit ouais j'ai trouvé
l'idée du siècle mais il est marié pas
laisser finir et je lui dis il ya une
différence entre les robots et les
humains louisy quand toi tu étais petit
par exemple il y avait une tache chaude
et donc tu as touché la tâche au tu t'es
brûlé logiquement donc le jour d'après
quand a revu cette chaude
est-ce que tu va la toucher non tu vas
apprendre des erreurs tu vas pas
persévérer dans l'erreur donc pour ça je
lui dis qu'à une locution latine qui le
dit parfaitement
c'est humain nous est révélé les
diaboliques ont donc à tandis que les
robots eux ils n'ont pas de réflexion
prend fin ils n'ont pas de cerveau
humain donc dans un monde rempli de
robots il répète peut-être tout sans
défaut ok mais home
monde de résoudre un problème ils savent
quoi faire parce que comme je viens te
dire ils n'ont pas de réflexion propre
donc ils percevront dans l'erreur
diabolicum ça serait un peu comme comme
rouler avec avec une voiture mais avec à
drouot en forme de carré dans un monde
de robots en serait incapable d'évoluer
on serait incapable d'avancer le monde
resterait pareil avec les mêmes les
mêmes les mêmes problèmes non résolus
jeudi c'est la fin j'ai tout expliqué je
suis content allez on retourne et qu'est
ce qui m'a fait il m'a encore faisait
une question mais il a dit que c'était
la dernière cette fois il m'a dit et toi
et car qu'est ce que tu aurais répondu à
la question sur ce qui nous rend des
humains et donc et donc je lui ai dit je
crois que c'est assez clair je lui ai un
peu expliqué tout et tout enfin j'ai
toujours parlé la même chose mais bon je
vais comme te répondre toi tu es un
enfant curieux d'un enfant qui se posent
des questions mais les gens de
l'antiquité les gens au moyen-âge les
gens au fil des siècles ont fait la même
chose
l'être humain aime réflexif aime
réfléchir j'aurai donc dit que c'est
notre réflexion
c'est notre faculté à réfléchir et à
donc trouver des solutions a donc
trouver des solutions aux erreurs qu'on
a commises et donc c'est ça ce qui nous
rend humain et comme on est les seuls à
avoir ça avoir cette réflexion on en
faire un bon usage
car selon des chercheurs la fin de la
civilisation pour avoir lu en 2050 à
cause du changement climatique causé par
l'excessive exploitation des ressources
naturelles par l'homme donc pour cette
crise pour ce qu'on doit réagir face à
nos erreurs qu'on l'a toujours fait on a
trouvé des solutions
on doit trouver des solutions mais on ne
va pas être égoïste on a donc pensé aux
prochaines narration au prochain pack 1
le temps de vie limitée et au profit que
l'on peut faire parce que lui dit à la
fin nous sommes les responsables du
futur des animaux du futur de la planète
mais aussi de ton nom notre futur le
futur des humains et car si l'on
continue à persévérer
perseverare diabolicum qu'est-ce qui se
passe ben voilà on risque de détruire la
seule planète que nous
jamais habité on risque donc de ckx
tendre comme des dinosaures
donc voilà après après mon discours un
peu un peu mélancolique
il était un peu triste mais bon il n'est
pas resté comme ça longtemps et il me
dit bon moi j'ai espoir en l'homme moi
j'ai vraiment espoir parce que
premièrement on est unique et spéciaux
parmi la planète
on va avoir un futur heureux c'est
seydou fils à ses il n'y a pas d'autre
option
et je sais donc on va résoudre cette
situation chaotique et et après ironie
dont il me dit bon allez carte a trop
parlé
on devrait peut tourner à la à la
famille enfin avec la famille pour fêter
pour fêter le début du nouvel an parce
qu'on a vraiment besoin de ça et donc
après ces discussions entre cousins nous
c'est les brames le début de l'année
[Applaudissements]